tomorrow is the last day of our great
toy drive you can drop off your
donations off at Tobin Auto Group the
sponsors of this segment where they're
all about toys and tradition
all right chop this you know I'm sorry
to highlight both so I can hear but this
is pretty cool I think we need a Dodge
Ram puzzle we sell everything we sell
vws we sell every type of vehicle right
here at Tobin Auto Group we got every
type of car you can ever want in the
Valley Auto Mall it's whatever it's it's
VW puzzles it's Dodge puzzles Kia
puzzles Alpha Romeo puzzles whatever it
is it's for the kids right and that's
what we're doing here we are donating
toys for the great toy drive going till
December 16th for the shade tree what
kind of toys can we donate any unwrapped
toys for the boys and girls bring in
bikes bringing any type of toy
um uh gift cards for the teenagers
anything we can do that the kiddos would
like you know probably headphones cool
stuff you know things the kids would
like but we'll take anything we just
appreciate all the folks that have
dropped off the toys we're gonna take a
picture with you hitting our gun making
some noise dropping the toy off if you
want to slide in quiet we got you either
way however you want to do it we're
going to we're gonna accommodate you got
everybody here now okay you talked you
mentioned the gong this is important I
want to understand this is tradition
what what is the story behind the gun on
so we've always had a gun so when you
sell a car we celebrate I always like to
do things unique One of a Kind try to be
a little different than the competition
and so we've always done a Gong and then
we did our TV show the one Global 21
countries king of cars on a e and what
happened was we had the gong on there
and then gong dealerships started buying
guns so we got a free gong just showed
up in the mail one day and so I was like
this is crazy and then and the gentleman
that owned the Gun Company he said that
people are buying guns he was about to
go out of business so he actually was
now opening his second location so he
said it's because us you know we're out
here so he said there's one from my
office and then a big one for the
dealership should we hit it yeah let's
do it Tobin the gift that keeps giving
okay all right I'm gonna I'm gonna hand
you the mic because I feel like there's
a technique to this okay here we go team
you guys ready
okay here we go
here we go here we go Rocky I want to
congratulate Rocky for the personal
Dodge Ram from trouble number one nation
Dodge in a rocky